we all know the famous saying workers of
the world embrace monarchy or not it
won't surprise you to know that
communist revolutionaries and monarchies
don't exactly get along and whenever a
communist revolution occurs in a kingdom
or an empire the ruler is often swiftly
removed one way or another yet in 1979
granada which is here had its own
communist revolution which turned it
into a one-party marxist state with one
notable difference it kept queen
elizabeth ii as its head of state thus
making grenada a communist monarchy
which you know why why did communist
grenada keep its monarchy intact so as
of the 1960s the british empire was well
on its way to no longer existing grenada
was slowly given more and more autonomy
until it gained its independence in 1974
and its new government kept the existing
monarchy in place because it made the
transition to independent government
much smoother it also helped to maintain
good relations with britain which was a
major trade partner in 1976 grenada's
incumbent prime minister eric gary won
re-election like other elections he did
this by getting the most votes however
unlike other elections he did not do
this by having better policies but by
having his secret police assault anyone
who wasn't going to vote for him the
opposition the marxist new jewel
movement refused to accept the results
because obviously and so started to plan
to get rid of gary three years later
whilst gary was away the njm launched a
coupon overthrew the government and it
placed its leader maurice bishop in
charge his government then arrested the
queen's representative there the
governor general paul scoon who was soon
afterwards released and the communists
kept him in his position so why well the
reason was that keeping the monarchy
suited the government's short-term needs
the governor-general was required to
stay politically neutral and school was
willing to stay on despite his own
opposition to the new government this
was useful for bishop since keeping the
governor-general gave the government
much more international legitimacy
although that's not how the british
monarchy or government saw it speaking
of which the second reason that
communist granada kept the crown was to
improve relations with the united
kingdom as well as keeping its place in
the commonwealth the uk government led
by margaret thatcher was especially
unhappy with the communist coup and thus
they sanctioned the country but bishop
kept the governor general because as he
saw it british governments changed
fairly often whereas his would stay
there forever meaning that irrespective
of how long it took relations would be
normalized eventually but beyond this
having a governor-general gave the
grenadian government a direct link to
the ruler of these countries without
having to go through their governments
who didn't like them this lessened
grenada's international isolation but
also allowed for some mild top-down
pressure to be applied to the rest of
the commonwealth now whilst none of this
happened the british monarchy was also
happy to maintain a governor general in
granada for similar reasons when a
colony abolishes the monarchy it doesn't
often come back and as far as the
british were concerned the communist
government would eventually fall and
when it did the monarchy would be the
sole legitimate power in the country
allowing for it to continue so basically
both sides were expecting to outlive the
other whilst using the governor general
to legitimize their presence there it
wouldn't be long until these plans were
tested since in 1983 bishop's government
fractured he was seen as not communist
enough and too dictatorial as such he
was captured executed and his deputy
prime minister took over only for
himself to be ousted five days later and
replaced with a military hunter to the
united states the coup there presented
an opportunity at this stage of the cold
war communist and communist aligned
governments were on the rise across the
americas and so toppling the grenadian
government would undermine that rise and
also rob cuba of any friendly neighbors
and thus after the governor-general
appealed for help the u.s along with
jamaica and barbados invaded the country
to overthrow the government as a result
the grenadine communist monarchy was
toppled leaving the rest of the world
thereafter a little bit puzzled by the
entire thing i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker corso wolff
jerry lamden jordan longley adam stalter
y and hockey captain cydog rod d martin
marvin castle spencer lightfoot gustav
swan common yoon boogery wiggly matthew
shipley marcus asner the mc whopper
aaron the white max and flaurio maggie
paxkowski corey turner alex schwinn
anthony beckett spinning three plates
copper tone words about books podcast
winston k wood charles the first ben
evinson and scottish trekkie